how'd you like that halftime show yes I
thought that was fantastic
JLo Shakira that was incredible was not
it was hot yeah I was gyrating in front
of the TV but I do that with every show
right right do that when I watch the
news kids were crying it was fantastic
Anat today there's all these like
different facts I didn't know about the
halftime show did you know this Jennifer
Lopez's 11 year old daughter performed
with her mother during the halftime show
yeah great
afterwards JLo admitted I couldn't find
a sitter so stand there what oh this is
interesting earnest away and president
Trump's legal adviser Jenna Ellis
criticized the Super Bowl halftime show
as demeaning to women yeah yeah she said
the President believes there's a time
and a place to demean women and that's
Twitter Iowa caucuses tonight yeah it's
gonna be interesting to see what happens
there was a false rumor that John Kerry
was going to announce he's running for
president yeah yeah parently people
assume since he's an elderly white guy
with no chance of winning he must be
running to help cover the 2020 election
the new site BuzzFeed is hiring
teenagers to make tik-tok videos yeah
yeah after hearing this Bernie Sanders
said okay slow down and say that whole
thing again
I don't understand what you're talking
about I just don't understand what
you're talking about
my Bernie Sanders is an angry old ape